meps debated the consequences of the war
in ukraine on the eu with commission
president ursula fonder lyon and
demanded support for countries facing
the brunt of its effects the eu will
work to phase out imports of russian
crude oil within 6 months
49 proposals with more than 300 measures
came out of the conference on the future
of europe
mep said that to implement them treaty
changes will be needed
[Music]
parliament's proposed eu electoral
reform changes include giving europeans
a second vote for a list of 28 meps in
an eu-wide constituency on top of their
vote in national constituencies
mep highlighted the importance of media
freedom and paid tribute to reporters as
they marked world press freedom day at
least seven journalists have been killed
since russia invaded ukraine
thousands of tons of old chargers end up
in landfill every year to reduce waste
parliament set out its position for one
common charger for devices like phones
and tablets the usbc
[Music]
you